[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i'm all in chicago the grizzly animal
in chicago your mom
it's funny that grizzly animal
don't don't talk about my mother well
it's just a joke
relax yeah my mother's very pretty she's
a beautiful woman unlike your cross-eyed
mother
don't you you don't have to [ __ ] get
i'm not bobby mudder
i'm i'm bobby mom you're so [ __ ] mean
dude let's pretend that we're in hawaii
this is what's gonna happen
yeah i'm your mother yeah and you're you
and we're seeing a waterfall for the
first time ready
yeah yeah bobby stop peeing
i'm your [ __ ] mom oh i'm fine you're
you oh that's the waterfall what do you
why did you think bob you're pissing in
this [ __ ] evidence because of this it
was like
can we back up though you're bobby lee
who else are you supposed to be in this
[ __ ] scenario i don't know there's
other people going there's two
characters in this scene
you and your [ __ ] mom which one do
you think you
should be well like which one do you
think i think i'm closely i think
i better understand the character of
bobby lee you're right
do you would you like to be your mother
and i'll be you yeah
okay let's do that let's roll play okay
here we go i'm going to write the
waterfall
i'm bobby lee i want to do this
ma'am mom mom do you do you like
waterfall have you ever seen before
that's exactly what you sound like do
you like water
do i really sound like that you
sometimes do yeah oh god mom
how do you like the waterfall
okay you don't like too much let go back
hotel
why i i'm tired
oh okay well water waterfall here first
time for you
all right you're doing a dad fan
impression no i'm not
you're doing it dad phantom all right
i'll be you i'll be bobby ready all
right mom why don't you like sound why
don't you do the sound
[Laughter]
why don't you like the waterfall mom i'm
being you but i'm just why don't you i'm
not me now oh [ __ ] yeah that's right you
[ __ ] it up bobby this waterfall crazy
no it's not it's the same accident you
[ __ ] [ __ ] how is it the same
dude don't do me do me a real quick mom
mom you like the water power okay i
didn't do my mom bobby this your
waterfall
oh yeah yeah yeah that's a little
different it's a little different it's a
little different yeah who are you going
to vote for
huh who are you going to vote for uh in
the november election yeah
uh d-o-n-a-l-d-t-o-o-u-m-m
[Laughter]
if you were to choose andrew and i
right if you're gay who would you [ __ ]
who would you prefer to [ __ ] me or
andrew
me [ __ ] or me getting [ __ ] oh
that's a very very good question
very good question oh you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
andrew how much body hair do you have
almost none actually i'm actually i'm
not i'm not hairy at all
just answer the [ __ ] question yeah
but let me think i mean i don't like
hair
yeah i think andrew might have a nice
ass yeah so
like nice [ __ ] into us but bobby
seems more like
feminine and he has more curves and i
probably want to hold his
breasts i think i think
i think her shoes your bobby yeah bobby
you got it
you got one i don't give a [ __ ] dude
what you said i
won that you have a full more feminine
you want to hold your tits i love this
kala was so difficult
to get what do you mean oh to like get
as a girlfriend yeah i mean it was i i
was like
i might have people that get this one
yeah first of all she's like none of us
what none of us thought so
[ __ ] you when i first saw kalila i was
like and i met her not when i saw her
how about this take away just her that
she's pretty
yeah when i saw that she was so cool and
nice and sweet yeah
i i was a little annoyed yeah yeah
but that was your girlfriend let's play
a scenario right yeah
you're you're out you're with uh you're
wi you're with um
not kalila because that's too good it's
got to be somebody who's uh
somebody who works for you like like
gilbert okay i'm with gil okay you're
out with gilbert yeah right gilbert's
kind of he's a very nice guy
he's a little quiet but he's he also is
very like he commands right
you guys are at like cafe 101 okay ready
and then you're sitting there with
gilbert just you know be talking to
gilbert about something
guy your face is so flat today that's
something i would say i know i don't
keep going yeah yeah
she's like what do you mean i know it's
just like you did a 100 yard dash in a
90 yard gym
yeah but like i hit a wall that fat yeah
hey yo what's up you bobby lee
yeah yeah i don't like your comedy at
all
okay yes to here man okay well you're
also in my [ __ ] booth i sit there
so get out of my [ __ ] booth no get
out of my [ __ ]
booth okay let's go gilbert
i said well no once but you did say no
once the first time but the second time
well after that you don't want to fight
this guy forever why did you do it that
way you [ __ ] [ __ ] you got so
aggressive right up
that would never happen what are you
studying now i'm in
i'm in high school senior senior year
you're a senior in high school
all right yeah and so when um
you were talking about jerking off you
know that was cool sorry about that
you know what i mean sorry jules yes
how's high school going
yeah it's comfortable now yeah how was
high school good
in here all the time she's our um she's
okay so
you know i'm dead i'm you know i'm
dating kurosawa yes
yeah and kurosawa is from uh the island
yes the phalapons
yeah and um apparently they have
families
as well over there like everyone else
yeah and uh she has um
a sister her name is honey and honey has
a daughter
happens to be her okay right so she yeah
so that
how horrible is that to live with him
it's okay
well okay so that's great that you said
that that's the honest that's an honest
reaction okay
so we're started there we started there
so let's get some of those let's get
some specifics
specifics out what what is something
that i do that
you don't agree with uh
maybe mostly everything okay well that's
now an
attack santina booger collection what
about the booger collection jewels
um he puts boogers in my room
like at the side and then i told him not
to put it and then he said
you can't tell me what to do and he was
serious
yeah bobby why are you torturing her
like that
that's good how was that tom he's 49
years old
and he puts boogers under her sweet
child yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you all right
i'm sorry i apologize but i just want to
say this to defend myself
i've never had a teenager in the house
before yeah i don't
i didn't buy the book yeah right there's
no instructions
yeah so i just don't know what to do
yeah bobby there is no book but if there
was
it certainly would say don't put boogers
on them here's the situation you pulled
into a gas station yeah yeah and i
i we're both kind of waiting for a pump
you got you kind of
snuck in there before me but you
technically it's yours okay
but you but you know what i mean yeah
okay okay ready
you get out of your car we'll say go
ahead all right so gilbert did you
used to drive a steam roller and you
fell off and your head got that way
no man all right i'm going to pump gas
hey bro yeah man i i i was here too i
was waiting for this
for this spot you you like literally
just swooped in front of me and took
over the bomb
actually i was my car was a little ahead
of yours and i you know that
i was in front of you so you you weren't
in front of me and i think what you're
doing is [ __ ] rude
all right dude um how much is gas for
you my car my
co to fill up my car yeah it's about 285
dollars here you go
you're just gonna give me your money
yeah shut the [ __ ] up
really shut your [ __ ] poor face up my
gas is eight hundred dollars
i wouldn't is that 280 yeah well you
already paid you
[ __ ] dumb idiot i wouldn't do that um
let's rewind a little bit ready yeah go
ahead hey man you no seriously you did
cut me off like i want you to apologize
to me for that
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
hold on hey man you stole my i you stole
my pump i was here first
relax dude i was ahead of you and i'm my
i'm like the things the nozzle's already
in my car i'm pumping
okay well i want you to take out the
nozzle cancel your credit i'm not doing
that dude
i was here i don't give a [ __ ] call the
cops i don't give a [ __ ] you know what
what i want to call the cops call them
you're not going to say sorry for
cutting me off i will not say sorry for
the end of my life i won't what's your
name
dominic dominic what cruz
the actor no the mma fighter the mma
fighter dominic cruz
yeah that's you yeah you're the [ __ ]
thank you who's that ugly flat-faced kid
in the car
it's a tiki statue i got from hawaii
who's this lady though you know what
maybe i too
could be ninja i want to be
ninja i
want to be ninja
i learn to trap you hard i fight with
credit card
[Music]
this video came out a long time ago but
i saw it again in my i was deleting
stuff
yeah i want to let you let's just hear
the chorus again oh no please don't tur
it's gonna
be the worst day
[Music]
i learned my ninja cakes while watching
netflix
i try to everything like on the big
screen
and you guys you know what i might do it
i might be a ninja soon
i gonna be ninja
this asian lady how is she standing
there through this there's four minutes
of this
all right first of all if i was that
agent
[Music]
turn it off okay it's off all right if i
was that asian lady
[Music]
down to chinatown
it makes me so it makes me feel like the
rudest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
yeah yeah
i was going through my folders at my old
on my phone because she doesn't realize
how difficult it's so rude how difficult
it is to be a ninja
yeah the levels are insane she could
never be ninja yeah because there's
different levels number one you have to
be able to climb a tree
she can't climb a tree there's no way
there's no chance right number one two
you have to have this enough breath
stamina to [ __ ] do the blow gun
yeah it's you gotta have that she
doesn't have any she doesn't have that
she has to be able to throw a star hard
enough to puncture skin
let's see the course one more time it's
one of my favorite courses
this
[Music]
she almost a ninja
[Music]
take chow down to chinatown
this is the most racist [ __ ] i've ever
heard of my life and it makes me laugh
so hard i had a girlfriend once her name
was sarah and she lived in
louisville i know who she is you do you
i know her she's a comic yeah she was
right or she is
yes she still does it and um
i stayed did she want to be ninja no she
i stayed at her parents house
and she goes so um we're having a
special dinner for you
this actually happened this is so good
already i already know what it is no you
do
no no i mean am i special we're having a
special dinner for you but so you have
to
sit in the i guess white people in the
midwest or
in the south they have basements yeah we
love
basements yeah i've never been in a
basement before well there's a purpose
for it we have those we have those in
the midwest for tornadoes and [ __ ] we
need to go down there
all right my bad also extra square
footage it's really good so i'm in a
great real estate basement
and i was there for about 45 minutes and
she comes down
and sarah's wearing kimono
and she go and it's mind you there's 20
people there
yeah her grandparents on both sides yep
uncles aunts right so i go what
why are you wearing kimono you'll see
so we go upstairs the whole place
right has she put bamboo on the walls
okay there's um like swords on the wall
too like
samurai swords i like it the grandmother
everyone they wear the mascara
right chinese eyes would scare off i
walk into the [ __ ]
dining room shut up i swear to god they
bowed to you oh yeah yeah
what was that they said what how to
church
yeah right and then
she goes take your shirt off i go why
you have to wear this shirt
it's an extra small pokemon shirt
so i put this extra stomach pokemon
shirt on and it's like you know me
super tight soup i can i can barely
breathe yeah
and i'm sitting there and then
everyone's wearing chopsticks but we're
eating like
um what white people eat um
like roast turkey we usually eat oh what
do you mean oh
no no chinese food at all no they didn't
even make they didn't even try to make
it
i had to use i remember using chopsticks
to pick up stuffing
which is very difficult to do by the way
do you think her mom told
do you think that was a bit she's funny
right she was funny she's very funny was
laughing yeah having a good time and i'm
kind of laughing too
but deep down outside is this is the
price you pay to get white [ __ ]
no no no no i already know what you're
going to bring up it's fine i can talk
about it
but i have to protect the the entity
itself okay that'd be protected that's
fine
what is it is um he's how many days now
15 days 15 days of no pornography
wow wow wait how about how bad was your
problem steve
it wasn't that it was
bad bad it was that i didn't like i
didn't like what
pornography was doing to my mind sure
sure because i realized
i mean because you know we're messed up
i mean i'm not blaming him
don't he definitely i know we have
nothing to do i know i know but you you
don't quote me but i just remember
it was a progressive thing as far as i
remember younger
this is before the internet like him
having like a dvd
he had a whole like collection of them
and i would take one or two and then
how many three you
[Laughter]
he could have filled up like an amoeba
record like a whole store
i mean yeah you know those one of those
booklets
you know those booklets where you put
cds
well you know those boys those big black
thick booklets like
he had hundreds of those collections
ain't no right way just the wrong way